[Music]
so we hit set we go we say I had
everybody I drink some hot chocolate I
don't know the same drinks I drink some
hot tea and then uh and then after
walking through the set and just getting
a look at it Sam myself Adrian and the
ad would sit down and we would talk
about what we are doing that day so
usually at that point we just literally
take a script and we read through it
together here's the scene say this we
say this we say this we do this hmm then
we take a whiteboard and we draw the map
an overhead map of the scene we start
breaking down our shots exactly and that
involves everything from where actors
are gonna be where hammers gonna be even
sometimes like alright everyone else can
hang out here and just stage older
equipment here because we're never going
to see this part for the day for this
particular shot after we're done placing
those little pieces then we order them
as well so we make sure we have an
efficient pattern - you know achieve
each shot and setup that we need yeah
you don't have to go into that plan
making the explicit written plan the
whole day things always change yeah it's
a way for you to get started and get
things figured out so this are you'll
just talk about shots you want I want to
close upon this and I want a wide over
here and I want to get this shot over
here and after you kind of talk about
all those shots and where people are
gonna go then you start thinking about
well it'll be smart if we do these three
shots first except way everybody can be
over here and then the next time you
know after that we'll flip we'll do
these three shots so everybody moves
over here there's any male except I'm
out lights Adrienne's working with Chris
Miller and the lighting teams the gaffer
to figure out where the lights are gonna
go where we're gonna light things and
you only had a limited number of lights
so for example on vault one we lit the
big room where all the Marines were
first and then we timed it so that they
could tear those lights down and put
them in the vault to light the vault
firmly shot inside the vault and then
they could tear those down and move the
lights to the back room for Miller's
little Miller the character is little
run through or a Isis a bunch of guys
yeah in Action Hero fashion exactly so
once we have that basic structure down
of our shots in order then we kind of
turn it over to our ad and we also go to
the other departments and talk about the
general structure for the day so usually
I would start by going to Sparky who is
our armor he's handling all the blank
weapons I'd say so we see these
characters would be
guns at this time and then later in the
day he's and so on and so forth and so
he'd go begin preparing all that stuff
we then go talk to like Nils and say
knows we have these stunts at this time
of the day and then we're gonna do in
this order so get the guy on fire here
and got the guys being thrown through
the window here I don't know like we're
in a patio so he does stabs and so
basically starts just going through
every single department trying to
communicate all right this is the order
we're doing it here's the board so you
can see where things are going to happen
and the order in which they will happen
yeah
Nigel you would talk to the art team you
know saying we need this prop here we
need this prop here we need these things
done here and usually by that point the
actors are getting their makeup finished
they're in costume you only start
talking to actors about the scenes that
we're going to shoot yeah I think right
through the script ourselves we talked
about it and so we'd get them at least
preliminary thinking about here's things
you got to think about here's a
challenge we're gonna face the day here
something I got to ask you et cetera
then the actors are all on the set
what's the very next thing we do is and
start doing a just a reading or so we
don't really worry about blocking yet we
J I have them save the lines unless
you've memorized this so yeah the
biggest generally before we even start
going off of that plan um the main thing
is all right so we finally have
everything we need there for the scene
we have our actors all the props in the
wardrobe everything in the background
like general enough yeah things are
mostly decorated so we're all generally
there but before we even record the key
to making everything work is just having
people just walk the walk you know that
they're not acting they're just you know
generally getting comfortable in the
space and this allows everybody
everybody to just generally see what's
happening that in in the scene and that
this is basically just called blocking
so we block the scene this just allows
everyone the opportunity to just see
what the heck is going on yeah because
sometimes it comes off one way on the
page and then on set it looks completely
different than what people were
expecting so we just need to make sure
it's super clear all right this is what
we're doing is where the cameras gonna
be and once we're set
well suppose I do blocking then we do
our camera rehearsal for the first shot
we start setting up the first shot is
blocking you'll tend to kind of just
block the whole scene it's good because
it gives people idea where they're
coming from
they're going and it's better just film
a whole segment and get your coverage
for the moments you need and to try to
like start and stop and start to stop
start stop and get all the little bits
you just just do the whole freaking
thing and so after that we'll move into
our cameras or take our cameras and we
are always running two cameras so we
would take our cameras we'd set them up
and we start running the scene with
cameras to see if the angles working and
that's when the final tweaks start
coming into place like okay when you
adjust the blocking over here and you
adjust the slide over here you know
sound is checking their height for the
microphone with where they can stand
we're adjusting angles a little bit
based on everything and then at that
point we actually pause and then any
actors that need a lavalier mic run up
into their costume tend to go get Mike
at that point everyone gets there's a
last look space again where we have
everything generally pretty much ready
to go and that way everyone can come in
everyone tweaks their own little thing
sound tweaks the sound art Pete's the
art guns tweaks the guns
hackers asking questions I tweaked the
actors you go yeah and then we start
rolling and we tended to do is we'd roll
like two or three takes and then you
join the last thing we either throw a
curve ball direction or ask for the
special ask for the special give us the
Jeff special the loo special actually we
never called the actors by their names
instead we'd always called them by their
character names
yeah Mueller special offset sometimes we
even call them like in real life
sometimes I'd call them like their
character name yeah a little weird but
they prefer it they differ and that
lasts a little bit when you give them
that curveball you have the special
doesn't everything from spontaneous
again because they first everything
they've practiced everything they
blocked everything and they're done over
and over and over and it can be good but
you lose a little that spark that we
have a bit of natural figure out
potatoes on real Park yeah this doesn't
feel rehearsed yeah and so at the end
you throw that curveball and everything
is all comfortable they know their lines
they're moving through it's moving they
can finally start reacting to things for
real in the moment and that's where you
get to go performance
[Music]